hello freak [ __ ] so before we end
this Canelo or Gennady golovkin oh my
god what a [ __ ] fight well you ladies
Mexican so you got a route for Canelo
otherwise I'm rooting for Canelo I'm
rooting for a good performance
Brennan Chavez that's what I do that's
what you do I do I have to none but this
case yep why because I want to see what
happens I'm I want to see what happens I
don't I don't have like a guy I want to
win like if Jeannie triple G wins I'm
not gonna be bummed out no I just want
to kiss fight exactly I want to see what
happens but I'm that guy I don't see
either guy lose hmm like I like both of
them I don't want a guy to lose I don't
have that L oh yeah with that little kid
punched that guy in the deck that's his
son punched that guy in the dick
Billy Joe Saunders he's a great
following little kid on the [ __ ]
scale my guys like no don't do that dude
and Sal look at this he's flexing kids
on the scale and he just like what's up
little man he punched him gonna kick and
he kicked him that's so [ __ ] up that's
such a bad look well it's so stupid that
they let that little kid be there what
if he punched that kid right in the face
shut the [ __ ] up at least slap him if he
kicked him be good to good to go Thai
boxing shots she's [ __ ] right yeah
you can't add extra shots to a caveman
Nigel a shirt a picture tape Fletcher
can consume he can throw that caveman
nitro down like it's water let's just
wrap this up before you shoot yourself
I'm gonna throw up and [ __ ] myself what
do you think's going on here not good
this is my prediction I think if triple
G doesn't stop them
Canella wins in a decision the public's
pissed because you all look at the
politics of it Golden Boy sighs wait a
minute you're saying if triple G hold
the music please you saying of triple G
out boxes and we won't get the decision
nope
boxing for you I think you would because
I think it sets up to rematch
I think you're imagining on irwadi even
if it gives decisions those no one gets
stopped so you really think that if
triple G puts on a show and outbox you
don't know how does something like for
like ten rounds which I don't think you
will I think if it's even close like
let's say it's like seven to six
something like some crazy you know yeah
my concern with Canelo is that he might
not have the endurance for a prolonged
firefight and you think triple G does
cuz he got against Jacobs Jacobs no that
was a goddamn firefight as well and come
on a fight it's close I thought I'd give
it yeah but Jacobs complete different
fighting the canal just II just watch
that the other day great fight I forgot
how good it was Jacobs is a [ __ ]
here's some space on my DVR so I was
deleting some boxing match that goes why
do I have a hundred Ted Nugent spirit of
the wild safety so I got to that fight I
said let me wash this again cuz this
triple G fights coming up this weekend
that was it Jacobs can fight his ass off
that was a great fight toughest fight
for triple G go he's over the hill we
know Jacobs just loads yet and
completely different violent Canelo his
footwork can makes me wish Terence
Crawford was just a little bigger I know
he's about 45 now we go up to 47 he
wants to fight Pacquiao yeah but I wish
she was like 160 you know he too cuz
yeah thin fella you know but I just
don't know I think part of like his
style is like he's built perfect for the
way he fights yeah you know that's
perfect endurance if you put more weight
on him he probably weighed down a little
bit slow him down like he that he's
definitely in his zone but forty forty
seven yeah that's the right way o'clock
since I'm a killer year man because now
they have anti Joshua he's fighting and
then you have the JIT Goliath
heavyweight champion built like a statue
looks like a Greek god yeah and then you
know like really well-spoken super
polite Under Armour and British guy yeah
and then you got a wild or Deontay
Wilder fighting
[ __ ] what's the name the [ __ ]
Cuban killer oh yeah King Kong yes it's
fighting him yeah I think it's a rough
fight for yes I think it's a bad idea
though the winners of each of those will
fight yeah it's a good time for boxing
but tomorrow's the big one
tomorrow's the big one tomorrow like
really can't wait shows who the
superstar in boxing is coz lomachenko
I think is like one of the most skillful
guys ever but he's not being challenged
there's not like a lot of drawl well
there's also not a guy in his division
that stands out as being the guy who has
to fight he's like Mighty Mouse yeah
whereas like Canelo and triple G's the
fight that everybody's want to see for a
while I think you'll get a trillion
elbow up who knows who knows how it
plays out
I can't wait though yeah I wonder I
really wonder what's gonna happen I'm
super fascinated me too
[Applause]
[Music]